[Music]
I'm going to show a series of miniature
games uh cuz I think these games are
easier to remember and if you're going
to memorize games it's easy to remember
games which are fairly short and
hopefully you can um take some
inspiration there's a lot of cool
openings which I'll show today so the
first game I want to show I played back
many years ago I was 15 years old and I
was playing in the US Open it's one of
the biggest tournaments in the US and it
was in
Indianapolis and I was having a really
good tournament um I was on one of the
top boards in the last round and in the
ninth round ninth and last round I was
playing Grandmaster John fedowitz anyone
heard of
him has anyone been across the street to
the World Chess Hall of
Fame no so John D is actually um I think
inducted into the US Chess Hall of Fame
and he was inducted into the Hall of
Fame the day before I played him at the
US
Open
and um it was it was actually a good
time to play him because he had like
this whole thing he had to go to the day
before and I think by the time we
started the game he was not in the right
mindset to play chess and I'll show you
a picture before we get started of uh
was one person taking pictures of us as
we were playing the game so this is him
this is me uh it was a very intense game
uh we both were sitting down thinking um
for for most of the game um but it was a
very quick game what's
that it was a classical game uh at US
Open US Open games can go up to 6 hours
I know it was uh 2 hours per player with
a
an additional yeah hour after
40 um
luckily half yeah luckily in this game
we didn't reach move 40 we reached move
16 and he resigned so I'll show you how
to beat a GM in 16 moves um I was black
which is even harder to do if you're
black against a GM to win quickly but um
but we'll see what happens so D4 D5 C4
E6 uh Queen's gamit declines which I was
expecting cuz um I looked him up before
the game that's one thing you can do if
you ever play a strong player or a
Grandmaster you can look them up online
and see what openings they play and it's
usually a good idea uh if you have some
idea of what your opponent plays before
you actually play them so you're uh
you're prepared of what you might get
into uh Knight C3 Knight F6 he takes I
take so this is a queen's gamut declined
exchange Vari
um very popular opening among a lot of
strong players
yes I was just do this like I know okay
you know okay um so we uh we continue
Bishop G5 this is the main line and in
this position black typically has two
moves um white already has a threat
white wants to take on F6 and kind of
pressure the D5 Pawn if uh Bishop take
F6 Queen take F6 Knight take D5 would be
possible so the two main moves for black
in this position are Bishop E7 breaking
the pin or the move that I played C6
solid move uh he played
E3 and I played Bishop to
F5 so so far not too much eventful has
happened we're we're actually following
Mainline Theory and does anyone know
this line or has seen this line before
yeah few of you you guys know uh what is
the main move for Whit in this position
queen3 yeah Queen F3 is the main line
and I think there was a pretty
well-known game uh several months ago
with Carlson and Carlson karnick where
uh Carlson won a beautiful positional
game after Queen F3 with the idea Bishop
G6 take take take take and it's an end
game or queenless middle game I guess
you could say where white has some uh
some positional play against the double
pawns and this was probably a more
practical and safer option for him but I
think because it was the last round and
because he was playing someone much
lower rated than him I was 2100 at the
time he decided that he would want to
try and beat me quickly so he went a
little bit crazy in this position and he
played Pawn
G4 very crazy
move the first question is can black
take the pawn on
G4 few people say no anyone think black
can get away with Bishop take G G4 no no
no Bishop takes G4 loses tactically to
what move Queen AR Bishop take F6
yes uh Queen take G4 actually doesn't
quite work for white because after
Knight
take uh White does actually up a pawn
here so you have to take the Knight
first and then if take take it's
messy but uh take
take white has want a
piece so the G4 Pawn can't be taken and
I have to move my Bishop again but uh
the downside for white is he's expanded
very early on the king side and he's
he's weakened his King side to the point
where it might not be safe for him to
Castle later on so I calmly move back
Play Bishop to
E6 and he plays H3 supporting G4 so H3
um and this is kind of weird because
White has played G4 H3 and hasn't
focused on developing any of the king
side pieces
yet uh Bishop E7 breaking the pin so I'm
playing a bit more kind of standard
classical chess and he's trying to be
very creative uh Bishop
D3 Knight bd7 and now he plays another
very aggressive move F4 anyone see the
threat for
white what does white want to play next
move yes F5 F5 Bishop yeah simply
trapping the bishop
so yeah not only is he gaining space but
he has a one move tactical threat and
already I have to be careful and there's
not too many moves which defend against
F5 so let me POS the question black to
move and not lose a piece Argent Knight
B6 Knight B6 very good me too you too
Knight
B6 uh creating room for the bishop to
retreat and now if uh yeah if F5 then I
would play Just probably Bishop D7 or
Bishop
C8 um but he continues he played Knight
F3 and now I played a very tricky move I
played Queen
D6 and the point behind Queen D6 is it's
to discourage F5 because if he plays F5
what move could I
play you could um play
G3 yeah I could play Queen G3 right so
I'm uh I'm I'm trying to prevent him
from expanding further but then he he
very much surprised me and played F5
anyway showing no
fear and sometimes this is how you end
up being a much stronger player is you
put them in a situation where if they
over push you might uh you might get
some Counterattack and that's exactly
what happened this game white has very
much over pushed the king side and has
left himself with some holes and I
thought some for some time here because
I wasn't sure if Queen G3 leads to much
but um but after some thought I went
ahead I played Queen G3 and I uh I
forced him to kind of give up his
casting rights and now um as King has to
move he played King D2 I think he's
trying to run away to the queen
side and now now let me ask you guys
black to move how would you
continue
yes
G2 Queen G2 check um yeah Queen G2 is
interesting I think the problem with
Queen G2 is after Queen
E2 white is pretty much forcing a queen
trade and this is a general rule in
chess whenever you're attacking your
opponent's king or whenever your your
opponent's king is less safe you don't
want to trade Queens so moves like Queen
G2 or queen F2 aren't necessarily great
for black cuz it probably allows a queen
trade uh let me help you guys out like
Knight E Knight E4 yes maybe I don't
need to help you guys out Knight E4 um
when you're attacking you want to attack
with as many pieces as possible so this
just brings another piece into the
attack um I couldn't necessarily just
play Knight E4 quick because it's very
complicated um after 94 there's a lot
going on in the position two pieces are
attacking E4 my Pawn's defending E4 our
Bishops are now staring at each other my
Bishop on E6 is still
hanging his King is still very
centralized on D2 Knight go to C4 I have
Knight C4 possibilities maybe bishop B4
later possibilities I still have my
queen check
possibilities so it's a very very messy
and chaotic position and this is another
way people beat stronger players or
another way upsets occur is when the
position is very chaotic it's sometimes
difficult to navigate your way through
the chaos even if you're a grandmas it's
still maybe more likely that you'll make
a mistake in this position as
lights so um as we'll see it was pretty
complicated to a point where he did
blunder uh eventually um first he takes
on E4 I take he takes with Bishop so now
some dust has settled but um but the
position has opened up now some more
lines for my pieces and now I play Queen
F or no whoop this should B4 check was
not played Queen F2 check was played I
don't know why that was saved um Queen
F2 uh attacking the king and leaving
white with not too many moves
um I want to take a poll here as white
because white has if I'm counting
correctly four legal
moves yeah um I want you guys to think
for at least 30 seconds and then decide
on one move that you would play as
white you don't have to raise your hand
now I'll go through each move who votes
queen2 for white anyone one vote two
votes three votes
okay four votes for Queen
E2 okay uh who votes King
D3 no one who votes King
C3 no one who votes King
C1 one vote two vote three
votes some people voted twice yeah um
turns out there's only one good move for
white in this position the only good
move for white is King
C1 which he didn't play
um let's go through the other losing
moves which uh one of which he did play
um Queen
E2 loses to Bishop to or not Bishop B4
Knight to C4
check
uh taking advantage of the fact that
King is the only piece defending the
queen and after King D1 I could then
take on B2 check King D2 Bishop B4 check
and now I'm controlling all these
squares I'm forcing the king to move
away from uh from the lady and I'll take
on E2 next
move so Queen E2 loses by by force the
move he played was probably one of the
worst moves in the position King
C3 like Su out hising into and that's
one thing which kind of goes without
saying you should not develop your king
in the opening especially with Queens on
the board and um in chess we think that
the king is a strong piece but really
the king is a baby you want to protect
your baby and for some reason uh I guess
he forgot his very basic principles or
maybe he thought his King was for some
reason safe on on C3 so now it's black
it's it's Black's move um Argin do you
have a
suggestion Bishop B4 I was going to ask
you guys black to move but I think arjin
already found it Bishop B4 oh I found
do you agree Bishop B4 yeah um brings
out the
king exactly you're just dragging the
king up the board
and it took me it took me a few minutes
before I played Bishop B4 I saw it right
away but I I had to make sure that uh
that all the variations won for black so
I played Bishop B4 and he actually just
resigned immediately he didn't even test
me to see if uh if I could finish off
the game
so let's see what what would happen if
uh if he takes the bishop um first of
all King D3 is runs into Bishop C4 mates
so king take B4 how does black continue
um yes Queen Tak Queen take B2 very good
and now white is left with few options
all of which are bad Queen B3 loses a
queen king A5 gets
mated
so the only other move would be king
C5 black to
move
simp queen queen
A3 Queen A3 is
mates now I'm not sure if I would have
played this maybe I would see Queen A3
mate but I think a bit more funny is
Queen
B5 forcing the king further up the board
and at this point it's just embarrassing
for whites and he probably resigned
because he didn't want to get
embarrassed like this Castle yeah maybe
maybe there's some line where I could
castle with matate but um like Knight C8
get the king to C7 and then I could play
around with him but uh Queen B6 mate is
uh is simple
enough so it's embarrassing to have your
king walk all the way up the
board and your Grandmaster and you lose
in um in under 20 moves but um but
hopefully this gives you some
inspiration gives you some more um more
hope if you if you do play a grandm
they're not invincible and they they can
make huge mistakes too so in this case I
think uh maybe he was just unfocused for
for a move or maybe he was just not in
the right mindset but that stuff does
happen and when it does happen you want
to be thankful thankful for it because
it doesn't happen too
often I have some opening like some very
nice games and openings that I've
prepared I'm going to give you a choice
between two openings we can either look
on the white side where white plays E4
first move or we can look on the black
side black playing against D4 so I'm
going to show you two or three games in
the same opening and this is an opening
I learned few years ago and I played it
with some success in tournaments and I
played it with a lot of success online
it's a great Blitz opening and it is a
Gambit so D4 Knight F6 C4 E5 this is a
Budapest
Gambit and at first when I was first
kind of learning this I thought it was
way too risky looks very weird that you
just give up a center Pawn for seemingly
no reason but um the more I looked at it
the more I realized that black has a lot
of uh interesting
resources
so so the main move yeah is take the
pawn and then black will respond with
Knight to G4
and now you're attacking the pawn and
there's a lot of lines where you
accelerate your development so the first
game I'm going to show you is actually
the game which inspired me to play this
opening for black and it's a very
straight forward game um almost All
Black's moves are very
intuitive uh White will typically defend
the pawn black will black will continue
attacking the pawn white will
defend and black has this back on
B4 uh White will usually play Knight
D2 and now we attack the pawn one more
time with Queen
E7 and now black is already winning back
the pawn by force there's no way for
white to defend the pawn yeah
just so white uh White normally plays
this move A3 attempt to counter attack
against the
bishop and now very cool move from Black
uh any suggestions what would you do as
black in this
position
yes something like take something like
take take what you can take a lot of
things take the Knight take the knights
okay Bishop take Knights do you agree
Bishop take Knights Bishop take Knight
is a normal move but there's a a much
more creative move
here and actually the the best move and
the coolest move is Knight take
E5 which confuses a lot of people at
first because the bishop is still
hanging and let's say white takes a
bishop arjin Knight takes Knight D3
Knight to D3 yes smothered
mates kind of out of nowhere just
Checkmate after eight moves so amazingly
enough um according to magga database
there's been 53 games after a take B4
all all of which ended with kn3 mates
happened in
Olympiad one of the games happened in
the Olympiad it was one of the players
on the Indonesian women's team um one of
her very first tournament she uh she was
white she she took the bait on B4 and
then really got punished for it after
Knight
D3 um so this is a cool line not only
for uh for black to win very quickly but
you always uh have to kind of learn from
this concept where if your opponent
looks like they're giving you a free
piece you want to make sure that you're
very careful before you you take
it so there's there's other lines too
where the same concept
applies so uh one maybe a couple more
things about this line um of course
black of course white should not take
the bishop uh a lot of times white will
take on E5
and then what's interesting black can
again take back and ignore the bishop
because again Pawn take Bishop Knight D3
mates and then if white takes on
E5 black will then take on D2 take on D2
Queen take E5 it's a very reasonable
position for black I would probably
prefer black here just with the centered
Queen so any questions about this this
very quick game and it's it's a game you
should know by heart because if 53
people fell into the exact same trap
odds are more people will in the future
question let's say with a Knight Knight
C3 oh Knight C3 instead of yes instead
of D2 yes that's that's a good segue
into the next game uh because uh you
can't do the same trap you you can't do
you can't do queen E7 A3 Knight take E5
this doesn't work because the Knight has
to be on D2 yeah so let's go on to next
game is Ruben Stein as white against
vidmar anyone hear of Rubenstein
Rubenstein pretty famous player um
Rubenstein yeah
um he lived in the early 1900s uh one of
the top players in the world he lost
in a very quick game against the
Budapest so we'll see that game and he
was yeah he was white and he played
Knight
C3 and after Knight C3 uh what I
recommend for black and what vidmar
played was Queen
E7 just you want to win the pawn
Rubenstein defended the pawn with Queen
D5 now it's a bit trickier because you
actually don't win back the pawn by
force uh but black still gets some
counter play so black took take and now
very aggressive move from black Que
Queen A3 oh I think that take take yeah
great minds think alike so Queen A3
attacks the C pawn and poses some
questions for whites uh what happened
was Rook to
C1 defending the C
pawn and now black has uh a couple
options black could take on
A2 but then the queen is in somewhat of
a precarious situation and there's still
there's still some isues for black for
example white could play
H3 and then the Knight becomes very uh
misplaced so instead of taking on A2
black played a much better move black
played
F6 forcing the pawn to uh to either
capture or threatening to take on E5
next so white took on F6 black takes
back and black is now down upon Pawn
because we we've traded off the pawn
that uh that white had had on E5 um but
even though black is down a PA there's
some counterplay for it there's some
compensation and the good thing about
being down upon is that you have uh more
open files to work with now the f file
and E file are open for black and we'll
see how this plays a role uh later in
the game question you're just stretching
okay uh Queen
D2 D6 defending
C7 and now white played Knight D4 looks
like a very reasonable move um the
better move for white was Queen E3 check
which looks very strange but um it it
gives some problems for the black king
and for white players who might be
playing against the Budapest uh this is
a very goodlooking line for white if uh
if white knows this move Queen E3 but
that's not what happened Knight D4 was
played Castle
E3 very standard and from this point
forward every move that black plays for
the rest of the game has some threat to
it um first move very simple let capture
capture and now black continues the
initiative with Knight
E4 and now there's some problems for
white because the queen has to move off
the
diagonal and wherever the queen goes
Queen A5 check or queen B4 check will
come
and white will lose casting rights and
that's what happened Queen C2 Queen
A5 and now the king is forced to move
white can't block the check and even
though White's still up a pawn uh the
position becomes very favorable for
black so white played King
E2 um yeah let me let me ask you guys
what would you play as black in this
position raise your hand if you think
you uh you have a suggestion maybe
should
Bishop F5 do you agree Bishop F5 Bishop
F5 is probably the most natural move
develop the bishop to maybe pressure the
queen uh vidmar played something bit
stronger and a bit more
creative uh what he does is he
sacrifices plays Rook take F4 I saw that
you saw that okay
um what it does is it removes one of
White's best pieces and one of White's
best defenders uh the bishop on F4 was
really one of the only developed pieces
so vidmar gets rid of it so he can
continue uh with his attack so white has
to take and then Bishop
F5 and now
uh the E file has opened and Bishop F5
has its own threats um mainly Knight G3
threatening to win the queen so white is
in a very precarious situation uh White
played Queen
B2 I think the next move for black is
very straightforward Rook
E8 and yeah again black is threatening
some very nasty discoveries uh again
mainly Knight G3 so white pretty much
has to move the king and really the only
reasonable square is King
F3 and again we see the king developing
before the other pieces usually not the
best sign uh especially at the beginning
at the beginning of the game um but okay
black still now now has to prove the uh
the attack
and any ideas for black in this in this
position how can black keep the
initiative
going
[Music]
um you said Queen
D2 yeah offer trade
so unfortunately Queen D2 is not what
you want to do because it's trading
queens and when Queens come off the
board the king becomes a bit
safer and yeah maybe black has still
some initiative but um you're not going
to end up mating anytime
soon so it's funny you found the right
square but the wrong piece you should
put your knight on D2 Knight only other
move Knight D2 yeah uh attacking the
king for forcing the king to uh to
progress further uh King G3 was played
and that was something really kind of
strange and interesting happened black
repeated black played
94 and what white should have done was
repeat and play King back to F3 but
that's not what white
did and what what white did was play
King
H4 and then okay we can say stupid yes
uh then the game ended very easily for
black Rook E6 was played and now the
king is very short on squares Rook H6 is
coming uh King is trapped and the game
ended after Rook
H6 Bishop
H5 and don't forget about your queen on
A5 because it can also help participate
in the
attack there okay there's a lot of
winning moves here but the most forcing
is Rook take
H5 and
then yeah uh Bishop G6 and white
resigned after King H4 Queen H5
mates so this is a very nice game to
know by heart because I think uh both
sides played pretty intuitive moves
until black started sacrificing uh in a
pretty crazy manner to uh to continue
the attack and if we go back a bit
further I'll show you guys what would
have happened if white
repeated um um CU it turns out that
Knight D2 was not actually the best
move if Knight D2 were um if if uh okay
Knight D2 was played and after King G3
if King
F3 uh was was played um black would have
to find a different move because black
would not be satisfied with a draw here
especially with White's King so exposed
so the strongest move for black in this
position is to play
H5
very simply threatening Bishop
G4
and I think white would have lost
uh pretty quickly um and I'll show you
an example line so
G3 G3 is possible um G3 might run into
Knight D2 though look at this Knight D2
King G2 Bishop E4
check
that's so good looks prettyy good for
black H3 is another
try uh preventing Bishop
G4 and then black plays H4 very cool
move actually H4 is a hard move to find
if you don't see the idea uh what H4
does
is it threatens uh basically a forced
win so let's say white doesn't see the
threat and plays some move like Bishop
E2 black to move and win arjin
Knight
D2 oh Knight D2 actually wins as
well um yeah Knight D2 wins I didn't see
that uh even cooler is Queen
A3 because after Queen take A3 then you
mate on D2 yeah Knight D2 or queen
A3 uh so the best move for white instead
of Bishop E2 is to defend and to play
G4 giving the king some Square to run
back and then black can continue Knight
D2 King G2 and now we see a similar line
Bishop E4 King
G1 KN of
three do you guys know what a windmill
is in in real life but also in chess yes
um a windmill yeah is basically when you
have uh continual discover checks and
you can move back and and win materials
so this is one example of a windmill
where uh White's King is pretty much
stuck after whatever check black gives
for example Knight
D4 King G1 Knight back to F3 King
G2 um now unfortunately for black
there's no more material to win but this
is just a completely crushing position
for black um there's probably no need to
if black wanted you could probably play
Knight D2 and then take the Rook um but
even stronger would be just some move
like Queen C5 and White's just
completely
paralyzed so this whole line uh
especially after white lost castling
Rights was was very very bad and uh
black uh black definitely got the better
of light in this uh in this variation
any
questions okay I'm going to show one
more Budapest game just to give you even
more inspiration to play The Budapest
and then um now if we have time we'll
we'll finish off with one fun game so
let's go back and let me see if you guys
just remember Let's test your
memory so Budapest uh what move in this
position for black yeah shout out E5
take Knight G Knight G4 very good um
let's say Knight F3 last time we saw
Bishop F4 let's say Knight F3 do you
guys know the best move for black in
this
position
Knight C6 Knight C6 is possible and
Knight C6 would probably just transpose
into the other line after Bishop F4
nothing wrong with this um I would argue
that there's a stronger move for black
Arin F6 F6 not necessary you don't want
to trade off the pawn too
soon arent
again sorry que Queen
E7 there a stronger move Bishop C5
Bishop C5 you take advantage of the fact
that the bishop has not yet developed
and you can play Bishop
C5 essentially forcing
E3 and after E3 now the bishop is sort
of passive on on C1 make sense yes um
and then we continue play Knight
C6 uh White will normally just give up
trying to save the pawn if white does
try and be greedy and hold on to the
pawn we we have Queen
E7 and then there there's no way to win
the pawn
back so usually white will play Bishop
E2 you recapture on
E5 and now it's a pretty standard
position um but I wanted to show you one
more game uh at least from this position
because if you play The Budapest you
might get this a lot and or at least the
structure a lot and there's a very cool
idea which doesn't happen in too many
openings but happens in this uh in this
variation in particular so castle castle
nothing cool yet Knight
C3 Rook
E8 now
A3 and now what move seems like a good
move for black in this position what
move would you guys
play and that's actually a good kind of
thought process if it's white to move
white wants to play B4 so how do you
stop it A5 A5 very good and it's funny
because A5 there's actually two reasons
why black plays this move the most
obvious reason is to of course stop
B4 the less obvious reason is is uh
something we'll see yeah
arjent
um maybe but uh there's there's a better
reason so you'll see very shortly don't
worry
B3 so now black plays a very surprising
move you said
B6 possible but not quite yes Rook A6
Rook
A6 and if if you look at the games of
beginners a lot of beginners like to
develop their Rooks very quickly like
this uh but in this position it this
works out very nicely because the whole
sixth rank is open for black black
hasn't committed any pawns on the six
ranks so The Rook can swing over and
help out for a Kings side
attack and and um it's actually very
hard for white to to deal with cuz um
okay what what happened in the game I'll
show you is Bishop B2 was played it's
completing development Rook
H6 and now the Rook the queen can also
come in uh the bishop can also help
participate and all of a sudden black
has a lot of pieces with the potential
to attack on the king side and white
doesn't have too many def on the king
side so the game uh I'm showing you um
black won fairly quickly and two masters
were playing the game who whose names I
forget so we'll find out once uh once
the final move is played white played
H3 trying to slow down some of Black's
attack but H3 actually gives black a
Target to uh to focus on black simply
plays D6 and now there's ideas of
sacrificing the bishop
white plays Knight E4 looks like a
reasonable
move but black doesn't care black takes
on
H3 and I think this is just incredibly
strong because once White's King opens
up then there going to be a lot of lines
to attack on a lot of uh mating ideas so
in the game white took on
C5 the dumbest Mo the dumbest move
why then you then you have it's made in
two it's made in two maybe not quite but
what would you play as black I
should Bishop take G2 that was very
close to M Bishop take G2 and white just
lost both of
his pawns which were the really the only
things defending the king and now it's
just a party for black on the king side
with the queen coming to H4 The Rook
already on
H6 and that's one of the powerful things
about about this opening you've you've
made what was your most passive piece on
a one of your best attacking
pieces so Bishop take E5 was
played and then black simply plays Queen
H4 very straightforward met mates mate
threats uh Queen H1 is coming white
played
F4 and now Queen
G3 and white resigned uh the game was I
guess uh REITs against leg
key
um I guess white may have been unrated
but black was 24 over 2400 so um as we
can see white white sort of played like
naturally but got absolutely smashed
after this Rook A6 Rook H6
maneuver so if any of you are
considering playing this opening or even
if you're not looking to play The
Budapest it's still good to kind of
accumulate these types of ideas cuz they
do uh kind of come up in other openings
too so any
questions about this game I wanted to
show you guys a game which I played many
many years ago probably when I was
around arjun's age um I was like in
fourth or fifth grade and I played at
the national Scholastic tournament it
was actually the national Elementary
School
championships and back during that time
I had a coach uh pretty well-known coach
Tamara goovi Uh Russian trainer she
coached players like Yuri Schulman Boris
galand and when I was working with her
uh she gave me a notebook how was it
name Tamara goov goov goov yeah um and
the way we worked on openings we uh we
kept a notebook
of all my openings and we would write
them down move by move these days it's
much easier just you can save all your
openings to chess bace but back then
uh we had a notebook of all all the
lines that I played for white and for
black and she would sometimes just give
me like simple variations but sometimes
she would give me games and there was
one game she gave me for the white side
which uh I learned with her when I first
started uh taking lessons from her and
after a few years um of kind of knowing
the line and playing the line um I
actually played through the full game
that she gave me and I won without
really having to think all I had to do
was recall what was in the notebook so
I'll show you that game um I was white I
won in about I forget the exact move
count but it was around 18 moves and it
pretty it's pretty beautiful line
because white sacrifices a lot of
material for a mating attack so I play
E4 any E4 players here yeah one two
three four okay um this King's Pawn and
we go into pretty well-known line
Italian I play the Joko piano Pawn C3 do
you have a question white can actually
decide whether it's more going to be a
solid game I wouldn't call it passive
but white can play solidly or White can
play very aggressively so a solid move
here would be D3 and we see these days a
lot of grand Masters are playing this
they like to be solid but the more
aggressive move and the move I played is
D4 and we call this a m attack um
because what ends up happening is white
actually sacrifices a pawn for increased
initiative and increased attack um my
opponent took I took he plays Bishop B4
check now if we see I'm in check and my
E4 Pawn is
hanging
so I just I was playing the moves that I
recalled I played Knight to
C3 my opponent takes on e4 and we get
into this
position which was It was kind of the
starting position in my notebook and um
this position yeah white loses the pawn
doesn't win it back by force but simply
castles
and tries to take advantage of the fact
that White's king or that Black's King
is still in the
center um so now my opponent fell into a
uh pretty well-known trap he took on C
C3 twice he started with uh with Knight
takes C3 I play Pawn takes C3 he plays
Bishop takes
C3 so now whites down two
pawns and um and The Rook is hanging
what to do for whites
Arin Bishop A3 is one move yeah have you
seen this before and I believe Bishop A3
is considered to be the best move at
least according to the computer but
there's a different
move yeah que Queen E2 is a move
uh but not the move that I played uh the
move that I played is Queen
B3 was forgetting about The Rook on A1
and going after the F7
Pawn um so black took the The
Rook why not free material so now black
is up a rook and two pawns if I'm
counting correctly but for the rest of
the game I'm going to have a uh very
dangerous attack against the king I take
on F7
King
f8 and now now it's a matter of of
continuing the initiative for Whit um I
start with Bishop to
G5 almost trapping the queen Knight has
to move back to
E7 now the next move is a very very
important move for uh for white to play
um any ideas how to continue in this
position for whites 95 anyone agree
95 um yeah 95 is by far the best move
for a few reasons first of all it um
Bish G yeah it uh it aims to control the
F7 square one more time it also opens up
the F3 Square for the
queen so this is a move I played and I
should note like when I was playing this
game I was young kid I I knew all these
moves already um so there was really
nothing for me to to think about but as
I was playing the game I was taking a
few minutes on each move just to try
make it seem like I hadn't known the
line before so I I was trying to get my
opponent to kind of underestimate my
play so kind of a interesting
psychological trick um yeah black uh my
my opponent thought for a little bit and
then grabbed more material takes on
D4 it's little bit better practice to
S little bit so yeah sometimes I guess
it it depends how much you want to trick
your opponent but um
in this case I uh I decide to be a bit
more tricky um so Bishop take D4 and now
uh the move is I heard some people say
Bishop G6 this is simply a clearance
tactic the bishop doesn't want to be on
F7 the queen wants to be on F7 so I
simply move the bishop away and because
both the Knight and the bishop are still
controlling the square black can't take
either pieace if black takes the Knight
Queen F7 mates if black takes the bishop
Queen F7 mate makes sense so neither
piece can be taken but my opponent
didn't give up he saw this and he played
D5 blocking the
queen but now I play Queen F3
check and yeah it's looking pretty bad
for black all my pieces swarming around
the king and um okay it ended very
shortly I opponent played Bishop
F5 I simply take the
bishop it's it's not really a check but
um it sets up a lot of discoveries
against the
king um my opponent took the
Knight so okay black is now
up a rook in two pawns but it doesn't
matter at all because after Bishop E6
White's completely winning my opponent
uh gave up a bit quicker he played King
E8 and I play Queen F7 mates black could
try and survive but
uh it's not going to be too hopeful
after Bishop F6 I would just take and if
take it would be the same
mate so this is why it pays off to uh to
remember kind of quick miniature games
because sometimes uh your opponent will
stumble into a line like this
unknowingly and you can win a quick game
without having to think really at all so
any
questions uh I'm going to show you one
very very quick uh kind of miniature
just to cap things off uh it's a fun one
and I'm going to jump straight through
to the very final position this is
called breaking the
rules and just going to zoom through the
opening um
E4 it was a king's
Gambit and I was black this is a Blitz
game I played many years ago
and it ended with kind of a a funny idea
so
what happened is black was down a pawn
but I had some early initiative as we
saw in a lot of these games my opponent
played Bishop D2 I took on C3 and then
white played a a bad move here he was
trying to be tricky he should have taken
with the bishop or with the pawn but
instead he played Queen E2
check and this is a game I've shown to a
lot of people over the years um a lot of
people have a hard time finding the best
move here for black but I'll leave it up
to you guys black to move and play the
best
move to
B you're in check you can't take the
bishop
arent sorry K King D7 best
move amazingly enough I can develop my
king it's another clearance tactic
threatening Rook E8 winning the queen
problem for white is he has no time to
recapture the bishop on D3 because I'm
threatening Rook E8 so if Bishop take
Rook E8 wins the
queen so my opponent played Queen
G4 check
Argin King C6 King
C6 bringing the king out into the open
but um but again the Queen's attacked he
has no time to take my bishop and black
wins a piece by developing the
king uh then the game ended very quickly
I'll just show you next few moves uh
Queen F3 was played I take he takes and
then I played Queen F6 and the game
ended very soon it turns out that
White's King is probably more expos in
Black's King because there's threats of
both Queen take F4 and queen take
B2 so the game didn't last too much
longer so I thought this is a nice way
to end the lecture because the first
game we saw white develop the King and
got punished for it this time black
develops the king and gets rewarded for
it so hopefully these games inspire you
to play some um enterprising aggressive
and creative chess and I hope you
enjoyed it and uh have a good
[Music]
[Applause]
night